mark german has just confirmed that
apple had the mac pro ready months ago
but they ultimately scrapped it and if
you're wondering why the heck they would
do that i think i have figured it out i
put a bunch of puzzle pieces together
which i'm gonna talk about in this video
but not only that i'm also going to talk
about some exclusive leaks some new
leaks about the m2 extreme mac pro and
when exactly that is going to be coming
out so let's get started now if you
didn't already know i had an exclusive
interview with mark german the other day
where we discussed a bunch of different
topics and by the way we're at 999 000
subscribers so just please click that
button to help us reach a million but if
you didn't see that interview definitely
check it out on our channel because we
talked about the mac pro and once again
mark german said that apple had the m1
based mac pro ready to ship months ago
but it was ultimately scrapped and now
they're deciding to go with the m2
extreme mac pro which is the next family
based on the m2 chip and yes mark german
has talked about the m2 extreme chip
earlier this month on july 18th and
basically it's gonna contain four m2 max
dies put together with multiple versions
of their ultra fusion connector at least
in my opinion and it's going to lead to
insane performance now the most
interesting part about all of this is
that back at apple's march 8 event they
actually mentioned this listen
making our transition nearly complete
with just one more product to go mac pro
so apple themselves at their march event
said that they have their mac pro coming
now i wonder if at that point they plan
to scrap it or not because mark german
did think that the mac pro was going to
get revealed at wwdc but that did not
happen of course because they scrapped
it now here is the big
question
why in the world would apple scrap their
mac pro because we know that apple
announced a two-year apple silicon
transition and that should have ended
people are arguing at wwdc with the
announcement or at the very latest
probably november but because apple
chose to scrap the mac pro they are now
going back on their word because if you
watch the interview with mark german he
did mention that he thinks they're still
gonna announce the mac pro later this
year but it's not going to come out
until potentially spring or even summer
of next year so apple's two-year
transition is technically going out the
window so
why in the world would apple scrap it at
the last second well i think i have a
pretty good reason as we all know at
apple's march event they revealed their
mac studio with the new m1 ultra chip
which basically takes two m1 max dies
and puts them together using their ultra
fusion connector which basically wires
them up but when we started testing them
specifically testing two m1 ultra models
the 48 core bend model for the gpu and
the 64 gpu model we noticed something
really disappointing the 64 core model
was not scaling well at all it had a
very bad scaling compared to going from
the m1 max to the m1 ultra because
technically that's 33 percent more gpu
cores but here we're only seeing a 16
improvement and then it got even worse
for real world workloads like classroom
cycles gpu rendering and blender where
we barely got any improvement at all
going from the 48 to the 64. and getting
even worse when we tested our canon 8k
to 4k hvc torture test we had a tiny
tiny improvement for those extra cores
which is basically not even worth it at
all but the worst thing was that the gpu
actually throttled a lot more on the 64
core down to 752
megahertz but the crazy thing was that
it was not overheating at all the temps
were very cool sitting at only around 57
degrees celsius which means it was not a
temperature limit that was throttling
the system it was something else so we
started to ask questions and we actually
had a source reach out to us and confirm
that the m1 family of chips had a design
limitation which was a bottleneck in
terms of the tlb memory bandwidth and
that led to the scaling being very bad
especially on the m1 ultra chip and that
actually makes a lot of sense because
apple's marketing showed that the m1
ultra gpu can go up to 105 watts of
power but the highest we were able to
see in any workload was 86 watts which
is completely different than apple's
marketing said it should go up to and
that's why it makes sense that the
cooling system was overkill with us
barely seeing any temps being high at
all so when we were doing all this
testing and seeing how bad the scaling
was on the m1 ultra max studio i had a
thought where what if the mac pro with
the four die chip is gonna scale
absolutely terribly if the m1 ultra chip
was scaling that bad and what if that is
the reason why apple decided to scrap it
and hold off until the m2 extreme
version because our source let us know
that apple was working on fixing that
bandwidth limitation that happens when
apps are not properly optimized because
most developers were just doing a simple
translation to metal but they weren't
fully optimizing how the gpu uses the
memory and that's why we're getting
those scaling problems so that should be
fixed with the m2 ultra and m2 extreme
and that is why i think apple scrapped
the m1 family version and they're
waiting for the m2 extreme version and
that's the only reason i can think of
for them to scrap it and totally mess
their reputation up in terms of this
two-year transition and them not hitting
their deadline but now with that said
let's pivot over to the second part of
this video which is talking about the
new exclusive leaks that we found about
the upcoming mac pro and this is going
to be very interesting they actually
come from the mac rumors forum user
amethyst hopefully i'm saying that right
but he ended up leaking some details
about the 40 core apple silicon mac pro
that is around the corner and he posted
this on july 12th now before i get into
these details i want to show you guys
some reasons why this user is credible
well
it turns out that on march 3rd he made a
forum post saying that the next
workstation class mac will be called the
mac studio and he gave us some
interesting info first of all he said
that it's going to be powered by the m1
max times 2 which is the m1 ultra so he
was correct before the apple event on
march 8th he also said it's going to
have 20 cpu cores 48 gpu cores he said
that there's going to be a low end mac
display that's going to be launching
alongside it which would be an apple 5k
display he says he's only see the front
and then it closely resembles what the
apple pro display xdr looks like he
hasn't seen the back or the side so he
can't say any of that information now
what makes this very interesting is that
the very next day
nine to five mac released an exclusive
report saying that the mac studio is
coming and i personally believe that
their source was literally
amethyst
on the macromers forums because if you
go to his profile you go to his profile
posts
you'll see this little comment from
chance h miller saying hi can you send
an email to ninefymac.com or
signal and he says okay guys and if you
don't know who chance miller is he's
actually the lead editor at nine to five
mac as you can see right here so i
believe their exclusive source was
amethyst but going back to this post he
actually gave us a lot of very telling
and interesting information that also
connects with the mac pro first of all
somebody complains saying that i really
don't think apple will kill the mac pro
name what's your source for this and he
replied from what i know the mac pro
name may not be dropped but we will
still get the max studio which is
basically what is happening not only
that but he gave some info saying that
this is likely not the only
configuration in the lineup saying that
we might get other configurations of the
mac studio as well which is exactly what
we got and right here he says that he
had hands on with this machine this
monday before the event saying that it
is very fast which means somehow he was
able to get his hands on a prototype
machine and that makes sense because he
says he didn't see the hardware itself
but it was in a black cardboard box kind
of like apple was trying to hide the
design from whoever they sent it to but
as far as the box itself he says that
the dimensions of the box look like the
g4 cube he said he tested it in an
office environment and he didn't hear
any fans it was very quiet and this is
actually very interesting because on
march 7th we got some exclusive renders
of this new g4 cube ish mac studio next
to an external display from luke miani
and ian zelbo and of course luke showed
it off in his video with a bunch of
different
renders right here and he got pretty
close to the actual design but he wasn't
close now my theory is that luke miani
found that thread and he decided to
create these leaks based on what
amethyst said saying that it looks like
the g4 q but going even further his
source confirmed that the machine has 32
gigs of ram and he's saying that we
could even see a 128 gigabyte ram
version which is exactly what we got
with the mac studio and not only that
but he says his pal also has info about
a high-end imac which is interesting but
i'm going to leave that for another
video but here's where it gets really
crazy apparently his pal who we can't
say who his name is tells him that this
system is the third prototype that he
got but this is the first one that was
labeled mac studio on the about this mac
page with the previous two just being a
black box with the m1 max system and
apparently he's talking about the
software being pretty buggy as well now
the interesting part about that is that
whoever the source is they were
receiving multiple prototypes so it
makes me think
what if it could be
some kind of software developer that
apple sends their prototypes to because
if you think about it the only people
that will have access to prototype
machines
are the people who are testing their
software
with their new apple devices so i have
no idea who could it be i don't want to
reveal or anything i have no idea but
it's likely somebody who receives new
prototype machines to test with their
software so apple could create these
marketing videos but here is where the
important details about the mac pro come
in he says that he had a prototype mac
pro with an unreleased 38 core chip that
he has been testing last year now if you
think about that it points to
a 38 core unreleased intel xeon that was
supposed to ship with a w6800
x mpx module but it looks like apple
likely scrapped that intel machine
because earlier this month on july 12th
he put out another forum post saying
that a 40 core apple silicon mac pro is
coming around the corner with a pci
express slot and in terms of the details
there's 40 cores for the cpu 32
performance cores eight efficiency cores
which perfectly matches up to a quad die
chip
and a total of 128 gpu cores which is
exactly what mark german was saying the
mac pro would have now there's a chance
that he received this prototype and he
might receive another one with the new
m2 extreme chip later down the road or
apple might just plop in that chip when
they actually release it so i likely
believe that this guy whoever he is has
the mac pro and the interesting thing is
that it does not have any ram slots but
it does have
a pci express slot he tried to put in an
amd
6900 xt but it is not working at all
which likely means that apple is going
to have a custom gpu that goes into that
single
slot and in terms of the sample board
stability with mac os is great and then
he came back the next day to brag about
him having exclusive info about the mac
studio and saying that this person lives
very far away from him about a thousand
kilometers away so he wants to visit his
house and check it out and ps it
contains only one pci express slot so he
confirmed it only one slot however his
friend did say that he can't confirm
what the final configuration is gonna
look like or how much pci express slots
will be in the production unit but so
far the prototype has only one saying
that this is the first apple silicon
based board that he received with a pci
express slot which is a sign of the next
mac pro because the last mac pro
prototype he got was intel based that 38
core so it shows apple has the mac pro
done and ready and people are testing it
and let me remind you this is on july
13th which means he received the
prototype after wwdc
so apple is working on that release so
now with that said i gotta make sense of
the single pci express lot why in the
world would that make sense with apple
going from a ton of slots to just one
well maybe that's just the test board
maybe they're gonna have more but what
if they only decide to have one pci
express slot how would that make sense
well first of all maybe with apple
silicon there might be a limitation with
the actual number of lanes going out to
have extras for the pci express slots
maybe that's why they can only have one
and then another thought is that if
they're not going to support amd
graphics cards then what's the point of
having so many slots and also they used
to have a slot for the after burner card
which used to handle prores media
encoding and decoding but their new
chips actually have prores media engines
built in so there's no need for the
afterburner anymore and if you think
about it this new m2 extreme with four
m2 max dies is already going to be
extremely powerful in terms of the gpu
so i don't think apple really needs to
rely on having that many available slots
potentially to have dual mpx loss
because right now the current mac pro
with intel has dual slots for two
massive mpx modules however you could
get just a single card with dual gpus
built in which is actually the better
way to go because the way it works is
those dual gpus are seen as just one gpu
to the software which makes optimization
a lot easier and better compared to
having two different cards that have to
work together and it's just not as
efficient as having just a single card
with dual gpu so what if apple gives you
options for a custom apple gpu card both
with a single gpu and dual gpu and that
is enough for having external graphics
performance as an extra boost if you
don't have enough within the actual m2
extreme chip by itself and then going
even further if you're somebody who's
buying the mac pro and you're not doing
stuff with graphics then you can have
that extra pci express slot to maybe
place in some extra server storage like
a raid setup just slot it in like apple
sells or you can put in a different card
like an audio management card or let's
say a black magic video controller card
or anything else you just have one card
and apple would be able to work with
that limitation because they would be
able to make the mac pro smaller if it
only had one pci express slot so in my
opinion this is totally something apple
would do just give you one slot or maybe
this was just a prototype and the one
that we're actually gonna get could have
a bunch of slots who knows but i think
that source is correct and then finally
i want to finish off with another reason
why i think apple could have scrapped
the m1 family based mac pro and waited
for the m2 extreme because we did get a
report that tsmc was going to start mass
production of the new m2 pro chip on
three nanometer instead of five
nanometers so what if the five nanometer
model just got way too hot and it wasn't
as efficient they decided to scrap it
because it didn't scale that well and
they decided to wait on the three
nanometer version because they're going
to be able to make that huge package
smaller which is going to make it easier
to cool down especially since 3
nanometer is more efficient and they'll
basically have a smaller package so
maybe that's why they decided to wait
until the m2 extreme which is going to
scale better and it's going to be an
extremely powerful mac pro so let me
know what you think about all those
thoughts and those leaks down in the
comment section below if you disagree
with me or you agree and if you enjoy
the video click subscribe to help us
reach a million subscribers thank you
guys so much definitely check out one of
those two videos right there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]